I feel like it's not good for my insides
I love peeps keeps our dough I just
think food combinations are weird and
fun peeps who's doing this the team the
dye seeping into the pizza like look at
this colourful ass Pizza pretty good so
weird I like it
it tastes like pineapples on pizza it's
like a little sweet on top of a little
savory really good if I was smoking I'll
blow right now it'll be the best pizza
chicken wings is this no no I don't want
to cheers up yeah Cheers
no it isn't that bad though no no thank
you
tastes like chicken just as a sugar as
does everything right this is bad
chicken wings I don't want to blame the
peeps for this this is not the peeps
fault no other way to describe up the
sides fleshie we're ruining a star you
guys oh oh what it's not yeah I don't
eat pickles Danny go happen I love
pickles
that's what pickles - and I love peeps
oh maybe this won't be the worst a
terrible life choice
[Music]
this would be good if you're like drunk
or high well anything's gonna be I don't
know I don't think I can do it ma'am do
we have a spit can anyone throw up I
think a peep is a really good thing on
its own but if you try to put it with
other things that's really risky
turns out beeps I have a tofu of candy
do anything to him and make it taste
like whatever you want if you just try
hard enough they will say about peas is
that no matter what you put it on they
still really make it not awful there's
nothing with a peep that's that bad but
don't challenge them
[Music]